the mainstream Americans standpoint
Angela Davis is a controversial figure
a former commie a women's rights
champion an anti-capitalist there's just
no single label that defines her
[Music]
[Laughter]
and last September a civil rights
Institute in her hometown of Birmingham
in Alabama decided to honor her with the
prestigious award sparing no words of
praise one of the most globally
recognized champions of human rights
giving voice to those who are powerless
to speak but every time her record of
tireless campaigning for Human Rights
propels her further into the public eye
it provokes a furious outcry this time
was no exception and before she could be
presented with the award the Institute
caved in
upon a closer examination miss Davis's
statements and public record we
concluded that she unfortunately does
not meet all of the criteria on which
the award is based the Birmingham Civil
Rights Institute doesn't have any list
of criteria published for all to see but
Angela Davis believes the rights body
was triggered by her stance on Palestine
although the BCR I refused my requests
to reveal the substantive reasons for
this action I later learned that my long
term support of justice for Palestine
was at issue some Angela Davis fans
protested in the streets of Birmingham
some voice supports online this is
shameful I stand with my dear sister and
friend Angela Davis this guy Marc Lamont
Hill used to be a CNN contributor used
to be because one time he spoke out on
air in support of the rights of the
Palestinians and against Israeli
practices of crushing dissent we have an
opportunity to not just offer solidarity
in words but to commit to political
action grassroots action local action an
international action that will give us
what justice requires and that is a free
Palestine from the river to the sea but
apparently he chose the wrong
to do so the river and sea metaphor is
commonly used by Hamas one of Palestines
major political parties and a terrorist
organization in the u.s. playbook Mark
Lamont Hill was fired by the network
shortly after the incident and in fact
some legislators would like to see
Israel's most hardline critics
supporters of sanctions hit with a full
weight of the law trumps expunging bag
and Senator Marco Rubio recently
introduced the first bill of 2019 which
would encourage state authorities to
take action against companies supporting
the anti-israel boycott in fact laws
barring Israel boycotting businesses
from state contracts already exist in 26
states and although they're often faced
with opposition like Marco Rubio's
initiative it's absurd that the first
bill during the shutdown is legislation
which punishes Americans who exercise
their constitutional right to engage in
political activity
Angela Davis's candle shows how many
people would be happy to gag anyone
daring to publicly undermine Israel's
image
you